[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today all right
today's question comes from Marie in
Arizona Marie writes my husband charges
me 41% of my pay for rent and utilities
huh what wow lovely fellow I think we
can stop right there I do too
wow I I do you do you want me to read
the rest no you and I are friends we
hang out you know how rare it is that
I'm speechless and I'm just trying to
think of what it would be like if I sat
down with my wife and said uh I've done
the math you owe me anyway I work 30
hours a week and only make
$35,000 there's so much wrong here we
went through FPU so I have been debt
free for years but my husband has never
really been debt free you didn't go
through FPU I used about $80,000 to pay
my husband's debts to help him be
debt-free several times over the past 7
years but he doesn't stay debt free he
even racked up 14,000 behind my back I
refuse to pay the debt off after that I
don't have the money to help him nor do
I want to we keep our money separate now
till he cleans up his debt and learns to
handle money it's hard for me to save
money when I'm paying him that much of
what I make but he said if I had to go
rent an apartment I would pay that much
or oh gez or more I feel
stuck wow um
this guy needs the whiffle ball bat
treatment yeah there's very rare smack
him around a little bit geez this whole
thing is a wreck um Marie if I was you
or you were my sister or you were my
close friend I would tell you to um head
directly to a marriage counselor or a
therapist by yourself not a marriage
counselor because he's not going to go
because you're you're married to a
seven-year-old who has um access to
adult toys an adult Financial instit
institions and I would ask how do I
begin to separate myself from this
marriage because this is somebody who
has cheated on you over and over and
over and over again over and over again
and
um there's no way this doesn't just keep
happening and so you're right if you
have to go R in AP partment you'd pay
that much more anyway cool then that's
what I'm going to go do and it's very
very rare that I tell some that but this
is somebody that I guarantee you I I'd
be willing to I don't have a lot but I'd
be willing to bet what I got that this
isn't the only thing that he is um
cheating on you um this is not the only
way he's cheating on you um I can guar
do feel abusive to you 100% that this
kind of at this kind of behavior doesn't
happen if there's not an alcohol issue
if there's not a drug issue if there's
not somebody on the side issue if
there's not some emotional psychological
abuse this is a wreck yeah this just
this doesn't happen in a vacuum like
this and so
um just the language you're using tells
me you have had to separate yourself
from this marriage while being stuck
inside of it to keep yourself safe and
keep yourself fed and keep yourself
housed and it's time for you to be able
to breathe and to walk in your own home
and drop your shoulders instead of
tensing up even more so um I'd go sit
with a professional and begin to ask
that question and if he comes around and
says oh she's serious then good on y'all
I always love a last second um uh
everybody decides we're going to be
grown-ups but Marie you are you're an
abusive mess here and it's time it's
time to go sit with the professional
ASAP uh John I'm not a fan of Separation
certainly not divorce I know there are
cases where it needs to happen this one
feels like um I'm glad you told her to
go see a therapist my question putting
you on the spot
is um yes for her but I would tell her
tell me if I'm wrong push back here I'd
tell her in in the course of doing that
to go ahead and separate for the point
of there's no longer going to be you
paying him 41% of your pay for rent
utilities we're going to separate until
he gets a of reality this is crushing
her they're already living separately do
you have a problem with that no in fact
um that feels like he needs a wake up
call a 30-day separation just to C Let
the Smoke Clear is often really good and
when you do that you want to have um for
lack of better terms of contract here's
what I'm coming back here's here's where
we're going to meet at for lunch to talk
after 30 days
but yeah um this guy's living a
delusional life that she has continued
to duct tape um yeah together for him so
that he can keep flexing and walking
around Arizona as though he runs stuff
um it's time for her to get out of this
because this this kind of crap escalates
and it just gets worse and worse so it's
tough I hate this for you Marie create
your free every dollar budget today the
simplest way to budget for your life